we couldn't take IBS in the UFC it's
like dude it's a saing solution in the
body I don't we couldn't take anything
over 100 MLS or 100 cc's or vitamin C
yeah rehydrating with IV seems like if
us a break over here yeah they wanted to
Outlaw those because people were going
to use those to mask other peeds or
something right it's like drinking a
gallon of water so you can pass a PE
test yeah exactly I get it and you want
to have a clean sport but you also don't
want it to be so overbearing that all
I'm relegated to is a protein shake and
a multivitamin it's like I fight in the
cage for living I live this crazy
lifestyle let me enhance my body as much
as I can legally right